it's great to welcome Jessica piccolo
back to the program she is a senior
legal analyst for rewire which is a
daily online publication covering
reproductive justice today we are going
to talk about masterpiece cake shop the
Colorado Civil Rights Commission which
might be known to you as the gay wedding
cake case which is now before the
Supreme Court
so Jessica as with many of these types
of cases we can't even seem to get
agreement from from two sides at least
about what the case is about there are
some who say this is about anti LGBT
discrimination and others who say that
it is a case about religious freedom so
for people who don't know even the facts
of the case what is this about sure so
I'll give you guys a quick rundown on of
the facts so there's a couple who
same-sex couple who walked into
masterpiece cake shop they were looking
for a cake to celebrate their wedding
and they had been married in
Massachusetts and we're a Colorado
couple and so wanted to celebrate in
Colorado and Phillips who's the owner of
the cake shop refused to sell them a
cake once he realized basically who they
were and what they wanted and he said
you know I I won't sell a cake to you I
won't make a cake to you because I have
a religious objection to same-sex
marriage the couple filed a complaint
with the Colorado Commission of Human
Rights the Commission did an
investigation and found that the refusal
to serve the couple was in violation
with Colorado's anti-discrimination
statute in Colorado like a lot of other
state has an anti-discrimination statute
that says affectively you cannot
discriminate against folks on all of the
usual characteristics that we have in
civil rights laws so that would be you
know race national origin age but the
Colorado civil rights law as do many of
the states goes further and specifically
includes sexual orientation and so the
Commission very rightly said this is a
problem
Phillips appealed and the court of
appeals said it you know reaffirmed the
Commission's decision and then Alliance
defending freedom who represents
Phillips and and their conservative
litigation
grupe they filed a brief with the
Supreme Court the Supreme Court sat on
the case 19 times before taking it up so
that in and of itself is very
interesting so that's Philips side the
Commission side and has been argued by
the folks who have filed amici on behalf
of the couple detail the very long
history that this country has of
religious evangelicals in particular
trying to launch religious objections to
civil rights laws the Supreme Court has
already looked at this as an issue in
the case of Bob Jones V the United
States where Bob Jones University tried
to defend its decision to not allow
housing for interracial couples on the
grounds that it had a biblical objection
to that and the United States Supreme
Court said it was fine for the
government to pull its non profit tax
funding status in that case so this
should be a no-brainer the fact that it
is not is something that advocates
should pay attention to so there is an
argument that some defenders of the cake
baker are making which is that this is
not equivalent to we do not serve gay
people in our business they are saying
they have the option to participate or
not in the baking of cakes for gay
weddings which are a type of event and
that they are not actually refusing
service to the couple on the basis of
their identity that they're refusing
service on the basis that it's a type of
event for which they don't work is that
legally a valid distinction or argument
well I think it's a pretty facetious
argument on I mean I will you know i
anecdotal anecdotes aren't evidence but
I will just say for example that when I
got married I hired a bakery to make our
wedding cake and in no way shape or form
did they participate in the ceremony or
in any way do anything that suggested
they were endorsing the union that I was
entering into the folks who are
defending the Baker and Phillips has
made this argument as well are trying to
say that he's an artist and what he's
doing is purely expressive speech and
and you know as Justice Sonia Sotomayor
pointed out in oral arguments well there
are people
who consider themselves sandwich artists
does that mean if you have subway cater
your student event that they are somehow
endorsing the message of it it's really
I mean when you start to drill down into
it
Ludacris what about the idea and I'm
just thinking out loud here I mean I I
happen to think that this this should
that the Baker is wrong here right but
but in the or in in the interest of
playing devil's advocate and really
thinking through I was imagining a
scenario where a heterosexual couple
right maybe it's someone related to one
of the two men who were going to get
married if they were to come in and say
that they were buying a cake for the gay
wedding and they were of course a
heterosexual couple and the individual
Baker said I don't do cakes for gay
weddings for example would that be
different because again it's not refute
the couple that they're refusing to
provide something for that's coming into
place the order would be a heterosexual
couple but the eventual use of the cake
would be in a gay wedding does that
example support the Baker's argument in
some way it's a really excellent
hypothetical and I'm glad you asked it
because what it allows us to do is
really talk about you know the who or
versus the what is how I like to
describe this case right is an objection
to who or to what and your your example
flips that because you're absolutely
right it's not the Baker launching an
objection against the person but
refusing to participate in a ceremony if
they were fine part like giving the the
heterosexual couple or the the
heterosexual person the cake on their
behalf
it immediately undercuts their argument
because it is absolutely then about who
they are comfortable about serving they
claim it's about the what but you know
I'm not sure if that does that you know
that distinction it slicing the Apple
kind of thin but in my mind that
actually helps the couples case because
what it you know in that sense because
if if they agree to serve a heterosexual
person or a you know a heterosexual
couple regardless of what the event is
and even if it's event that they say
they object to then they're not
participating in that event with any
you know real you know it undercuts
their participation argument I was
actually thinking of the opposite which
is if they said even to the heterosexual
couple it's for gay weddings and that
that would actually in some sense
strengthen their argument in either case
we're talking about hypotheticals though
sure sure sure I mean I certainly think
that that is a compelling a more
compelling point to the Baker side
because it is again this idea of
objecting to or putting forward that
objection but it doesn't change the end
result that what they are objecting to
is something that is a legal right and
that is a legal right held by a
traditionally discriminated against
class of people so you can dress it up
in different ways but in terms of the
outcome it is still saying I have a
religious objection to a constitutional
right that you have and historically the
law has just not recognized that and
with good reason
yeah so that's kind of the bigger
picture here which is with a lot of
these types of legal debates you have a
sort of budding heads of freedom from
and freedom to in the sense that the
Colorado non-discrimination law by
including sexual orientation as a
protected class says that individuals
who are part of that members of that
class should be free from discrimination
and those on the other side say that our
religious freedom gives us freedom to
sort of exist in society in accordance
with our religious laws isn't that
really what's at issue here it is except
I would take that further because the
the balance that you described is
absolutely an important one and one that
traditionally has not been an issue
aside from what the the evangelicals
have pushed because it is possible to
recognize a myriad of religious beliefs
and also recognize the fundamental civil
rights of people in this country so I
think there's there's that part of it
and then in terms of really the larger
piece I would say that we this is an
example and it's been increasing
really since 2010 it's sort of gone on
hyper
under the Trump administration of
Evangelicals trying to use religious
objections and quite frankly weaponized
the First Amendment as both a sword to
puncture through civil rights laws and a
shield from the liability that happens
when they do so I mean frankly we saw
this with this setup with Hobby Lobby
they have great opening to do so now
yeah that was I mean when the Supreme
Court decided that state bans on
same-sex marriage were not going to fly
it was abundantly clear at that point
and the Hobby Lobby case was one of the
big notable examples that the shift in
the battle against LGBT rights was going
to move to religious freedom and and
still by the way I mentioned this
anytime that there's an opportunity to I
don't remember the number of states but
in many states you can still be fired
for your perceived or actual membership
identification as an LGBT individual and
that is a completely separate issue from
that of same-sex marriage and I don't
know if you have thoughts about where
where that's going oh absolutely the
Supreme Court just this week refused to
hear a case on that exact issue there's
currently what we call in the law a
circuit split so federal courts of
appeals are not in agreement as to
whether or not firing someone from the
workplace because they are gay amounts
to discrimination on the basis of sex
under title seven of the Civil Rights
Act which is the federal employment law
um so that is very much an open question
for debate now you know I mean it's
always reading the tea leaves in terms
of why the Supreme Court decides to take
up a case and why they don't you know I
I wrote a quick piece on this in terms
of why this particular case that they
considered may not have been a really
good candidate but this is absolutely an
issue we are going to see because
exactly what you mentioned in many
states is still possible to lose your
job because you're gay and there is you
know or it goes even further in terms of
like certain gender non-conforming
behaviors and stereotypes so you know
that in addition to the fight over how
the law recognizes the rights of
transgender people to is is really the
burgeoning civil rights battle that we
are seeing right now last thing to touch
on as far as this case goes that we we
started today's discussion about when
might we expect to
here a decision and what ultimately will
the decision hinge on in your mind okay
so the court was positively packed with
press to the point where we were given a
signed seat so this is likely the
biggest case or one of it's certainly
one of the biggest cases on the courts
term so that usually means an end of
June decision particularly since they
conferenced on it so long I think this
is going to be one to hash out I would
like to see it earlier in the sense that
I would hope be hopeful that it's an
easy question for the court to answer in
terms of what it hinges on as we have
seen time and time again a lot of the
outcome of this case hinges on Justice
Anthony Kennedy he has two real
competing legacies here he has the key
has his legacy of advancing LGBTQ rights
even if it has been slowly but you know
that's how the law works and really
working to insulate religious
individuals and in particular religious
conservatives to you know I mean I mean
he's he's the Hobby Lobby decision to
allow them space to exist in civil
rights laws that they did not have a
space to exist before and with good
reason and so we'll see where he comes
out in this case he was very concerned
about using civil rights laws to
discriminate against the LGBTQ
population
he was as concerned that ruling against
the Baker would somehow endorse what was
argued by the Baker as religious
discrimination by the State against
evangelicals so it's gonna be it's gonna
be a closed case I would expect a pretty
split along ideological lines decision
all right we will be following it we've
been speaking with Jessica picolo senior
legal analyst for rewire great to talk
to you again thank you so much for
having me back always such a pleasure